unlike prokaryotes in eukaryotes the
process of transcription is pretty
complicated it involves the elongation
but at the same time it involves quite a
lot of processing during the time of the
transcription like alternative splicing
forming a five-prime m7g cap and
polyadenylation
so all these modification has their own
significance and they help the RNA in
terms of stability or many other factors
so in this video our focus would be to
understand the polyadenylation process
that means adding the poly a tail to a
new carrier thick mRNA in this video we
would learn about the processes and then
enzymes and the steps involved in this
particular modification and also the
significance of the polyadenylation so
stay tuned and watch the video till end
now we all know that in eukaryotes the
transcription would take place inside
the nucleus now during the transcription
process elongation takes place and while
the mRNA is protruding out from the poly
car any polymerase there are several
enzymes getting attached to the
c-terminal domain of the RNA polymerase
like capping enzymes like alternative
splicing enzymes etc now while the
transcription process I mean that first
the elongation process is almost to an
end then there is a sequence which is a
a you Triple A at this sequence there
are specific proteins such as cpsf
cleavage and polyadenylation specific
specific factor and there are also other
sequence which is a little bit
downstream to that which is G or each
sequence where C tsf cleavage
stimulating factor binds and all these
enzymes which bind to these specific
regions has their particular
significance in terms of polyadenylation
once these enzymes bind to that region
there would be a dish
of a cleavage factor or CF this cleavage
factor cleaves the RNA in a specific
region downstream to a new triple-a site
and at that particular region
polyadenylation polymerase would bind to
the RNA and it's a template independent
polymerase so it would keep on adding a
in the mRNA and it would create a poly a
strand at the end of the mRNA something
around 50 to 100 nucleotides of adenine
residues would be added at the end of
these mRNA without any template now once
these polyadenylation is kind of
complete by polyadenylation polymerase
there would be other polyadenylation
binding protein which would bind to
those specific poly SI --tz--
at the tail of the mRNA and these has
significance having it has been shown
that having polyadenylation increase the
stability of eukaryotic mRNA simply that
means the amount of time that the
ribosome would engage with the mRNA
would be more so the round of Trance
then the number of rounds the mRNA could
be translated is more the amount of
protein that could be produced is also
altered so in terms of cellular
physiology these polyadenylation has a
big significance now it turns out that
polyadenylation helps in nuclear export
of the mRNA I mean from that if the mRNA
need to be translated it has to be
thrown out from the nucleus or exported
out to the nucleus onto the endoplasmic
reticulum where the ribosomes are which
can lead to translation reaction right
so first it needs to be exported out and
in that process the poly a tail turned
out to be very useful because it
interacts with the exporting proteins
and it's easy to export in that way now
in case of bacteria things are different
because in case of bacteria
poly a tail leads to its degradation but
in case of eukaryotic cells the
situation is completely different now
other than that the polyadenylation
binding protein also interact with the
initiation factor for a and for B these
are translation initiation factor so as
the poly a tail indirectly interact with
the initiation factor of translation it
makes sure's the mRNA is forming a close
circle like structure which allows
several ribosomes to be recruited on to
the mRNA simultaneously and that
regulates the translation and increase
the rate of the translation from the
same mRNA so it has a long-lasting
effect itself in terms of translation
rate now lastly but not the least
alternative polyadenylation site choice
is an important modification or
modification strategy taken by the cell
to create different proteins let's say
this particular mRNA has had mRNA which
is encoded from the DNA has six exons
now what happens is that while forming
the mRNA in different tissue let's say a
thyroid gland or let's say in the brain
different adenylation sites are used as
a result different lengths of mRNA is
produced so in first case there are only
four four exons are included but in the
last case six in true exons are included
and as a result completely different
protein product is produced for example
in the first case in the thyroid gland
calcitonin is produced where in the
second trace in the brain CG RP pepti is
produced so depending upon what
adenylation site is chosen a complete
different protein product could be
deduced from us same mRNA that leads to
a huge physiological significance of
polyadenylation site choice I hope this
video was pretty much infirmities and
simple to understand I hope you liked
this video if you
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and please comment how do you like the
videos and if you have any specific
suggestion thank you